welcome back to bucket of pops the only
game show where you get to fill a bucket
full of puppies we have three
contestants here today Sarah say hello
to the audience and Curly hey guys you
have 30 seconds to put as many puppies
in this bucket as possible if the
puppies escape feel free to put them
back in only one puppy at a time no
double fisting with puppies Curly's
first 30 seconds we have an escapee
[Music]
three puppies in the bucket how'd you
feel about greatly performance well he
did well yeah do you think it can be
three epochs has nothing on me does
everybody get ready
[Music]
that's one in the bucket
oh look at this - in the bucket three
Breanna here we go four in the bucket
[Music]
or puppies for Brianna in the bucket
for puppies how do you feel about that I
can do five five puppies all right get
the timer set go one puppy in the bucket
two puppies or puppies in the bucket
five four three more puppies in the
bucket
Oh
[Music]
or
[Music]
puppies in the bucket and today's winner
in bucket of pups Sarah congratulations
[Music]